at least the poster's laminated because
i saw some posters out there
i appreciate the effort
that's awesome so protesters out there
were holding signs on loose leaf paper
it's like come on
this guy he took the time to laminate
that thing with whatever that is
and i really appreciate it
like he had to go down to office space
or you know he had to go down to
to staples with that thing all right
anyway
leah thomas is a man back to the subject
in hand here
and i'll be using the word he in
reference to leah thomas and any other
man that i might refer to today in fact
i want to begin there with some thoughts
about language
because this is this issue is much
bigger than sports we've got to start
with the language
the trans agenda has infiltrated our
society largely through
language
now i don't mean that the gender
ideologues use language to make
compelling arguments no not at all they
have no compelling arguments as we just
saw there they have no arguments to make
at all
they don't even have coherent arguments
let alone compelling ones rather they
like to manipulate language itself they
make it into their into their pet they
talk about preferred pronouns
but a pronoun is a grammatical construct
it has to be deployed according to the
laws of grammar not the fickle whims of
the individual
now if i'm standing let's say on this
stage let's just call it a stage for the
purpose of the analogy and you want to
communicate to someone else about the
fact that i am standing on this stage
you will say to that person he is
standing on the stage it would be
grammatically and factually incorrect to
say she is standing on the stage as she
denotes a human female which i am not it
also be incorrect to say that they are
standing on the stage as that indicates
more than one person and i'm just one
person
and would be incorrect to say zee or zur
is standing on the stage
does that suggest that i'm some sort of
space alien which
as far as you know i'm not
now in a similar way if i am standing on
a stage and let's say that i insist that
my preferred preposition is off
it would make no sense for you to
respect my preferences and tell everyone
that i'm standing off the stage now i
may prefer the word off whatever that
means i i may think that i am off i may
identify as someone who stands off of
things not on them but that doesn't
change it doesn't change the objective
fact that i am indeed on the stage
prepositions nouns verbs and pronouns
unless they're used in a fictional story
or a poem or something
are meant to convey objective facts
about reality
now if they're not going to perform that
function then they no longer perform any
real function at all and meaningful
useful words have been reduced to
impotent nonsense
but should we just be polite and call
people by their preferred pronouns
anyway
the answer is no and here's why first of
all i think we should establish just a
general note here that
you don't really call somebody a pronoun
when you're speaking to them right if
you want to address a person directly
you usually use their name
and a name can be whatever you want it
to be if a woman says that her name is
fred or a man says his name is sally i
will call her fred and him sally because
names are by definition personal
subjective arbitrary
you know you could change your name if
you want no one can say you can't
pronouns are objective and also
generally more distant in the way that
they're used
you're usually called by a pronoun when
you're not physically present for the
conversation or at least when you're not
the one being addressed in the
conversation
so when someone insists on a preferred
pronoun he's trying to prevent you from
using proper grammar even when he's not
in the room with you
he's saying to you
whenever you refer to me even if i'm ten
thousand miles away
you must abandon the rules of proper
grammar and parrot whatever gibberish i
have assigned to you you must bark like
a dog on my command even when i'm not
even here
that's not only absurd it's also
arrogant in the extreme
that's the other thing you find about
the proponents of gender ideologies that
they are all every single one of them
massive narcissists
control hungry narcissists who think
they have the right to control
everything about society and everything
you say and do
they don't
that's just not how language works it's
not how life works
it's not my job
to enforce your self-perception
okay you might see yourself as a woman
but that's not how if you're a man
that's not how i see you
and that's not what you actually are and
so i cannot be required to affirm what i
do not believe and what i know to be
untrue
and further it is not my job to adopt
your perception of yourself whenever i'm
talking about you
what kind of nonsense is this
now look i might perceive myself as
handsome and intelligent
many of you are laughing you don't
perceive me that way and that's fine
what i cannot do is require that
everyone who speaks about me
must also have the same perception
my self perception is not a project that
i can assign to the entire world it's my
self perception
it's my business not anybody else's
second point
using an incorrect pronoun incorrect as
in a pronoun that does not properly
convey objective reality is not only
nonsensical it's also dishonest
so if i say she drove to the store when
i'm talking about a man
then i'm lying now i may be lying with
the best intentions i may be lying
because i'm trying not to hurt anybody's
feelings but a lie is a lie i am
conveying an untruth
and it is bad to convey untruths
because the person i'm speaking to
whoever it is deserves to know the truth
now if i didn't think they deserve to
know the truth and i shouldn't be saying
anything to them at all
and the person i'm referring to also
deserves to know the truth which is why
if i'm talking to someone directly
i'm not going to respect their preferred
pronouns
i will call them what they are to their
face
because a confused and deluded person
needs the truth he doesn't need us to
participate in and encourage his
delusion
now that may be what he wants but it's
not what he needs
and it won't help him in the long run
and at any rate he does he doesn't have
the right to control my speech or compel
me to lie on his behalf
but then we get to this question of what
doesn't grammar and language evolve over
time
well it does however language evolves
according to coherent rules and
standards
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about people making up
their own rules individually
which isn't evolution but degradation
fracturing collapse
see language is a is a symbol it's a
sound meant to represent something
we say elephant to talk about elephants
and camels to talk about camels but
things could have worked out so that we
say camels to talk about the animals
that we know as elephants and vice versa
there's no reason why we had to use
those particular sounds to represent
those animals it just worked out that
way
and so language can shift and change
over time but most changes in language
happen relatively organically
due to a wide combination of influences
people begin to slightly adjust the
verbal symbols they use for certain
things
and eventually the official grammatical
rule official grammatical rules change
you know to reflect that they change
descriptively not proscriptively
now what's happening with pronouns and
with all the language around gender
it's not like this this is a top-down
change
the grammar rules are being changed
proscriptively
our cultural elites have decided for
ideological reasons
that we ought to be using different
words and they plan to berate and scold
and punish us until we comply
that's not a natural evolution of
language
that's an intentional manipulation of
language
which is a very different thing
just look at what they're doing with the
made-up nonsensical word latinx or
latinx
i say latinx i think i think latinx is
how it's pronounced
um
now
almost nobody in the hispanic community
uses that word or likes it they've done
studies on this in many polls
very few like that word
yet the elites keep using it and pushing
it and pushing it hoping that eventually
people will submit and start adopting it
in daily use and if and when that day
happens
they'll then turn around and say look at
that language evolved
no calling that natural evolution it's
like injecting drugs into a lab rat
and then it grows a third ear and you
say it evolved
this is something that you did
now there have been other examples of
this kind of unnatural imposed evolution
of language african american
became the preferred term in the 90s to
supplant black and then went back to
black again that was replaced by people
of color which is considered politically
correct while colored people is
horrifically racist
now all of this is pretty arbitrary and
kind of ludicrous
and mostly the result of elites telling
us what words we should be using but
that's not nearly as bad as the pronoun
change
because in the former case the verbal
symbols to describe a certain reality
are being changed okay
but with pronouns they wish to change
the symbols and the thing that is being
symbolized
the point of making pronouns fluid is to
give the impression
that people are fluid
they're not just trying to change the
way we describe things
they also want to change that which is
being described
they don't simply want you to use
different words to describe certain men
they want you to see those men
differently as in fact the opposite of
what they actually are
they want you to think that they are not
men at all
now
that all may have seemed like a long
digression about grammar when really
we're supposed to be talking about
sports
but actually it's not a digression
because we're not really here to talk
about sports we're here rather to talk
about the truth
and that's what's under assault
not simply women's sports but truth
itself
now women's sports is just one
battleground in the war for truth that's
that's why i care about it
i freely admit that i am not exactly an
ardent fan of women's college swimming
in fact i can only name one women's
college swimmer and he's not even a
woman so
but
i am a fan of the truth
and of justice and common sense and all
of these things are under assault when
men are allowed to intrude
that's why it matters
now i've said that thomas is not a woman
and i've established why i will not
refer to him as such
but how do i know
that he's not a woman
well because the word woman just like
the word man has a definition
a woman by definition is an adult human
female that is the literal definition of
the word
a man by definition is an adult human
male
now those are the only two options
available for a human species
that's all you got you have no other
options there is no third sex it doesn't
exist
all humans who have ever lived
on earth have been either male or female
every single one
we call this a binary system
there are no non-binary people
and that's why if you want to go to
amazon and order a shirt with the
non-binary pride flag
it will come in either men's or women's
sizes
now
what is a female
that's the next question a woman is
adult human female well it's a female
okay
glad you asked
what is a female
well a female is someone with xx
chromosomes a female reproductive system
female gametes or eggs
the ability in principle to ovulate and
bear offspring
there are females who suffer from
illnesses mutations injuries deformities
maybe are simply postmenopausal and so
therefore are prevented from performing
some of these
natural female functions that doesn't
make them any less female
it is instead an exception that proves
the rule
here's why
when a female cannot bear children
we know that something is physically
wrong
something's gone wrong here if she's of
child-bearing age and she can't bear
children something is wrong something's
not working right
maybe it can be fixed maybe it can't but
we know that
because we know that women are supposed
to be able to bear children
but when a man cannot bear children
we know that that is not a sign that
anything has gone wrong
because men are not supposed to bear
children and no man in history ever has
or ever will
now if as a woman you go to the doctor
and tell him
that you're unable to conceive children
in your womb
he'll run some tests to figure out
what's wrong with your body
if as a man you go to the doctor and
tell him that you're unable to conceive
children in your womb
he should run tests to figure out what's
wrong with your brain
but
as it happens
the joke doesn't really work because our
society has lost its entire mind which
means that he might actually give you
hormone pills to help you transition
into a woman
but you'll note that and much to the
disappointment of some of the men who
have unfortunately gone
undergone this procedure without
realizing
even after becoming a woman
still
the man will not be able to ovulate will
not be able to conceive children
will not be will not be able to perform
any of the exclusively female functions
ever
because he is not a female and will
never ever be one
thomas is not a female and will never be
one he's a man a male with xy
chromosomes of male anatomy
as the women who've seen him in the
locker room have attested
male gametes
but there's a lot more to being a male
than just that i mean indeed the
physical differences between men and
women are not confined to the
reproductive system
they can be found in every bodily system
in every part of the body
you know leah thomas like any male
is male down to his bones down to his
cells down to his dna when he dies and
is buried beneath a giant monument
celebrating him as history's greatest
female athlete
100 years from now he could be excavated
and his bones analyzed and scientists
will be very confused to discover that
the greatest female athlete was a dude
his bones will attest to the biological
reality they will not declare his
pronouns his bones
they won't affirm his self-perception
because there will be no self the self
will be gone but the man will remain
think about that
when you die
one of the very last things to remain of
you is your sex
even after almost everything else is
gone
that's how fundamental it is
now many of these biological differences
happen to give him a distinct advantage
over women in sports especially swimming
when he gets in the pool this week here
at georgia tech he'll be swimming
against people
with 20 percent less muscle mass on
average
40 percent less upper body strength 33
less lower body strength smaller fast
twitch muscle fibers smaller lungs
smaller hearts shorter legs
more estrogen less testosterone
a lower capacity to produce oxygen when
they exert themselves
courageously thomas has chosen to race
against people who have literally dozens
of immutable biological disadvantages in
comparison to himself
what a hero
now these advantages are why the fastest
man in the world is always faster than
the fastest woman
does that mean that every man in the
world is faster than every woman of
course not
but the fastest man in the world is
always faster than the fastest woman and
you know what if the fastest man dies
the next fastest will still be faster
than the fastest woman
in fact if the 100 fastest men all got
on a plane
to go to a fastest man retreat
and then on the way tragically the plane
crashed and they all died
the 101st fastest man who is now the
fastest man by inheritance is still
faster by a lot than the fastest woman
and then the next 100 fastest men they
could also go to the same retreat
stupidly and die also
and the next batch of 100 are still
faster than the fastest woman
we could do the same thing with
strongest man for strongest we won't go
through the whole thing again
now the olympics attest to this there
has never been a time ever in history
not once when the women's racing or
swimming champions were faster on
average than the men it has never
happened in history
and never will
these advantages are why there's in fact
a whole website maybe you've seen this
dedicated to comparing high school boys
track and field champions against female
olympians
the high school boys outperformed the
female olympians in almost every
category
by huge margins
taking one example
the the new balance nationals outdoor
meet is one of the preeminent high
school track meets in the country if the
2016 high school boys finalists in the
100 meter race were to have raced
against the 2016 female olympic
finalists
the fastest woman would have come in
ninth place
against high school boys
ninth gold silver and bronze all go to
the boys
places four through eight all go to the
boys
against female olympians
now this this holds true in almost every
event and it's not just track and it's
not just hypothetical
some of this has actually been tested
back in 2017 a a team of 15 year old
boys
scrimmaged against the u.s women's
national soccer team
and beat them
five to two
which is just great first of all
um
male and female athletes are so
different separated by such a vast
biological chasm that you can actually
count the total number of dunks made by
the wnba players in the history of the
league like we can this is counted
because it's only happened 28 times
and 23 of them were by the same
player
now for comparison take sake there's a
player in the nba who dunked the ball
300 times by himself in one season
that's one player in one year dunking it
almost 10 times more than the entire w
nba over the course of a quarter century
men and women are different
very different
there's no denying it men are stronger
they are faster they are better at
almost every competitive sport
literally every line of evidence
supports this
all of the evidence all of it supports
the claim that men in general have
biological advantages over women in
sports
there is no evidence to the contrary
none
which is why you'll notice that the
people on that side never produce any
evidence they don't have it it doesn't
exist
they can't defend their position
they can't even really explain their
position because they run into a basic
logical problem which i've talked about
quite a bit and i'll talk about it again
here
so for example they say that leah thomas
is a woman right but they can't tell you
what they mean when they say that
what is a woman
now
gender theory has made it so that the
word woman itself and the word man have
no meaning
leftists because of their ideological
commitments cannot define the terms they
say trans women are women
they say that someone can start out life
as a woman and transition as a male and
transition into a woman but how can i
understand any of these claims and these
declarations if i don't know what they
mean by the word
and how can they make any meaningful
statements about womanhood
if they themselves don't know what they
mean by the word
so i ask very simply as i've been asking
for years as i asked on dr phil
what is a woman
now they say that biology has nothing to
do with womanhood okay
well what does have something to do with
womanhood
if we can't define a woman physically
how can we define her
what is a woman
what does it mean now if you're on the
left
what exactly are you trying to say
when you say that such and such
biological man as a woman what do you
what are you trying to convey about that
person what do you mean you say leah
thomas is a woman okay well what he's a
what
what does that mean exactly
it's a fair question isn't it
and i've been told by the few that
attempted to give an answer that a woman
is anyone who identifies as a woman
but that definition doesn't work because
you can't use the word you're defining
in the definition
if i ask you for the definition of an
apple
and you say an apple is that which is an
apple
you haven't really told me anything
about apples i still don't know what an
apple is
same goes for a woman now you might say
that a woman is an adult human female or
anybody who identifies as an adult human
female
that's just another way of saying that
that a woman is an adult human female or
not an adult human female
and that's just another way of saying
that a woman is nothing in particular
woman has no definition if that's the
definition
also the person offering that definition
is themselves drawing a distinction
between a person who is a thing and a
person who identifies as a thing
i mean the very phrase trans women are
women seems to admit
that trans women are not really women
because if they're women then why are
you calling them trans what does the
trans part denote
see the trans part seems to be pointing
to
some kind of elemental crucial
difference between these two categories
and i would say that that crucial
difference is what makes them separate
categories
when it comes down to it
if the word woman means nothing it's
nonsensical to identify as one given
that you're identifying as something
that's not really anything
now is a woman in the end just anybody
who enjoys feminine things or dresses in
a feminine way
you heal you hear these insane abusive
parents who say
you know my my four-year-old boy
really liked the little mermaid and
that's when we first realized he's a
girl
well see femininity though
cannot be the definite the defining
quality of being a woman because we
can't define feminine until we've
defined woman
as the definition of feminine is having
qualities or an appearance traditionally
associated with women
besides the left has been trying to
break down the societal constructs of
feminine versus masculine for years
how can you go from saying as i heard
all when i was growing up going back
again decades
it used to be well not all women should
be expected to be feminine
and now what the only defining
characteristic of a woman is femininity
for years and years and years they said
that they said in fact that if a boy
plays with a little mermaid who plays
with dolls there's nothing wrong with
that it's not girly
and now they're saying that if a boy
plays with dolls he actually is a girl
talk about reinforcing the gender binary
they can't answer these questions
they insist that our conception of
womanhood is wrong
and then we ask them what the right
conception is and they shrug their
shoulders
we don't know what a woman is they say
but whatever a woman is you know leah
thomas is that
that's nonsense
and we all know that it's nonsense
even most of them know the people
marching out outside with the signs
almost all of them know that this
doesn't make any sense
and yet we're supposed to cooperate with
it anyway
we're supposed to abandon all at once
the fundamental truth that all of us
know and have always known
and we're supposed to do it for no other
reason
then it will hurt people's feelings if
we don't
it'll hurt leah thomas's feelings
of course his feelings are the only
feelings that matter right when it comes
to the swimming issue
his feelings and the feelings of other
trans people i mean those feelings for
some reason are supposed to outweigh the
feelings of women who don't want their
sports destroyed and their privacy
invaded and their very identities
appropriated and stolen and cheapened
and fetishized
and turned into a halloween costume
the feelings of a million women are dust
when stacked up against the feelings of
one gender confused man
all of reality is dust
biology science truth all of it is
supposed to be thrown out the window
because of one trans person's feelings
well i say to that no
that's what i say
and i urge everyone in this room to say
no to this
don't affirm what you know are lies
everyone knows it's a lie
don't cooperate with what you know is
wrong
don't abandon what you know is true
don't pretend to believe what you don't
believe
it takes a lot of courage in this world
i think to say no it's a word that's not
said nearly enough
a guy like leah thomas has never heard
it in his life
ever
no one's ever told him no
no one's ever sat him down and said dude
no this is not happening
but he needs to hear it now all the
gender ideologues need to hear it now
all of the liars and frauds trying to
push and coerce and shame us into
surrendering our common sense all the
cry bullies using emotional blackmail
because they have no arguments
everyone demanding that we pretend to
believe what we don't believe
all of them everywhere
need to hear it
no
that's it for me thanks guys appreciate
it thank you
all right thank you we're gonna go ahead
and transition into the q a section
all right our first question
why isn't the women's rights movement
furious about this
well i think there's a real um
who am i talking about i guess i'm just
talking all you guys um
there's a real fracturing
in the women's rights movement right now
i think you know there are some
feminists
i don't give i don't give a feminist a
lot of credit for many things but
there are at least some feminists
who have noticed i think probably a
little bit too late
but they've noticed that the trans
agenda is undermining everything that
they have said and fought for
for decades
and so sorry um
and so i think that there's a there's a
real fracturing happening right now but
for the most part the reason why most
women's rights activists don't stand up
to this is because they're beholden
ultimately
to the left you know what we call
women's rights is not really about
women's rights it never really was
i mean when these are people who are
fighting for the right to kill babies
that's not women's rights
got nothing to do with rights at all
actually
so they're beholden to the left and in
the left there is a victim sort of
hierarchy and there's some jostling that
goes on on the victim hierarchy who's
the uber victim the top victim
whose victim claims already always
override everybody else
and right now
lgbt at the top and trans is at the top
of the lgbt
at the very top of the pyramid so i
think that's why
they're not stopping it
why should trans women be unable to
participate in sports due to
testosterone levels when cis women can
sometimes have comparable levels
okay
well
first of all as established
the difference between
a quote unquote trans woman
otherwise known as a biological male and
a quote unquote cis woman and that that
word doesn't mean anything by the way um
i think cis by the way that was like
invented by someone on a message board
seriously a couple of like a decade ago
or something and now it's just it's used
in academia but anyway
um the differences go way beyond
hormones so this is kind of a red
herring this focus on hormones
i i listed some of the many differences
between men and women biologically and
physically
does really hundreds of biological
differences hormones is just one of them
also another point
no one is saying
that quote unquote trans women
are not allowed to compete in sports
no one is trying to prevent trans people
from competing in sports nobody is
trying to prevent trans people from
using the bathroom no one's doing that
all we are saying is that the rules for
quote trans people should be exactly the
same as they are for everybody else
you're not special
so i can compete against men in sports
and i can use the men's bathroom because
i'm a biological male and all we're
saying is that if you are a trans person
you have to you have to obey the same
rule as me
so under the guise of wanting equality
as usual what they're actually asking
for is special treatment they want a
special rule special exception made just
for them
and that is uh
it's [ __ ] frankly
all right next question
why should we even bother having
gendered sports teams when it would be
clearly be more fair to have competition
based on levels similar to wrestling
weight classes but based on whatever the
relevant metric is for each sport
well if you start breaking up sports
that way then
it's just going to end up you're going
to back where you started and eventually
it's going to be
effectively it's going to be men and
women again because men
out compete the women
so much to begin with but also
why should we have to make of course if
you if you really if you do that and you
just get rid of the distinctions
um what will actually happen in the end
obviously is that there will be no more
women's sports there'll be no more women
competing because they'll get out
competing they're not gonna be able to
make any team if the men are invited in
all these same teams
um you know if you come if you collapse
for example the wnba in the nba
what the hell are the wnb players going
to do they're going to i mean they could
be they can
i guess run out the gatorade and stuff
like that but they're not going to be
able
well it's true
it's true there there is no wnba player
no wnb player who could make it on a nba
roster not even close okay i would have
a better chance of making an nba roster
with wnba
so
that's what would happen is you just you
women would be cut out of sports
completely
and my answer to that is why should we
have to do this why are we talking about
drastically reordering the way that we
approach sports and society
because a small sliver of people are
uncomfortable with the way that we've
been doing it forever
what instead of like having to
restructure everything for these people
why can't we say to them
i i'm sorry this makes you uncomfortable
it's just the way it is
deal with it
why is that not in effect a an
acceptable solution
you're a man you're uncomfortable using
the men's restroom
deal with it you know i don't know what
to tell you just deal with it why is
that why can't we just say that
is my question
okay
if trans women have such an advantage
over cis women then why is it that very
few trans women in competition are out
there dominating the field in fact with
leah thomas in particular why isn't she
number one in every event she competes
in
okay well
again no one is saying that every man
is better at every sport than every
woman that's not the point
we're talking about we're talking in
general here and i went through in the
speech of whoever wrote the question if
you were listening to the speech
i went through proving
that men in general out-compete women in
general
in almost every competitive sport and
it's not even close
so
the the the claim is not that any old
man can walk into
you know swim meet attract me and just
beat every woman that's there no one is
saying that
but he is going to have an enormous
advantage so what you actually have to
do
to you know kind of
see this
is you look at
the man
who's competing against women
how is he performing against the women
now compare that to how he performed
against the men
and that's where you're going to see the
advantage doesn't mean he's always going
to beat the women
but he's going to do a lot better
against the women that he did against
the man
really really good example of this was
up in connecticut there were two men
who in in boys rather high school track
and uh they were racing against boys for
a couple of years and then they decided
oh i'm a woman and they started racing
against the girls
and they didn't win every single track
meet
but they won a lot of them and when you
compare their times
you know they would go against the women
easily top three
against the boys they wouldn't even make
it on the track
you know you're taught you're going from
whatever 50th rank to third
that's where the advantage is
all right last question as a mom of a
young athlete what can i do to protect
women in sports
well
so this is this is one of those answers
it's kind of a easy for me to say
category
but um i mean i'm more than happy to
come here and talk about this and
explain why all this is wrong
but
what i'm saying only goes so far it's
it's only going to have so much impact
which is like not that much impact at
all frankly that's i still have to say
because it needs to be said
but the real impact is when the girls
who are
being subjected to this and their
parents
stand up and say we are not going to
take part in this
and so you want this to go away
on
wednesday thursday when all this is
happening the women who are supposed to
compete against leah thomas what they
need to say is i'm not going to do it
okay the the the
you know buzzer sounds
off to the races
just
sit there in the pool
and let him race by himself
and i guarantee you
it would only take women doing this for
like a few weeks
and this problem is done it's gone
so that's what
yeah
again
easy for me to say i'm not the one there
doing it but uh that that is in fact the
solution
and uh
we'll leave it there thanks
i'm just noticing now i was canceled on
one of these signs here well
how did this guy he was allowed in here
why did he get thrown out
okay all right well that's fine um okay
thanks a lot guys appreciate it
[Applause]
little button on the bottom
you